[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis ravie de vous
retrouver aujourd'hui dans ce nouveau
numéro du skycho le magazine qui raconte
toutes les aventures économiques du
territoire de
50 an eneveline alors aujourd'hui nous
nous trouvons au Technocentre du groupe
Renault plus précisément à l'intérieur
de son nouveau bâtiment entièrement
dédié à la simulation de conduite
immersive à Guill en cours ce nouvel
espace de 2300 m abrite le plus grand
simulateur de conduite immersif au monde
roads dans cette édition vous
découvrirez pourquoi ce tout nouvel
outil de simulation de conduite
immersive pourrait révolutionner la
conception des véhicules du groupe
Renault mais avant tout voici le
sommaire de ce nouveau numéro du skycho
une formation pour s'exercer au métier
du digital durant 10 jours un sprint
camp était proposé au campus numérique à
hencour création de sitite Internet ou
initiation à la cyberc scurité une
trentaine de participants a pu mettre en
place différents projets pour gagner de
nouvelles compétences numériques vous
découvrirez également dans ce numéro le
plus grand simulateur de conduite au
monde au Technocentre de renult group
puis au ski cube une table ronde se
tenait à destination des entreprises sur
le thème du mesena mais tout de suite
plonger dans l'univers du Spring
[Musique]
camp l'image elle est là elle est
parfaite et ben en fait j'ai fait aligné
à gauche oui du en fait ça déformé le
texte en fait démystifier un univers
parfois obscur c'est l'objectif du
sprint camp organisé au campus numérique
à hencour le concept s'initié à C
professions du digital gratuitement
durant 10 jours la trentaine de
participants cantinois a pu découvrir
les métiers de développeur cyberécurité
community manager ou web designer pour
ces personnes parfois élonies du monde
du travail pas de préquis seulement la
motivation d'apprendre c'est vraiment la
première étape
vers retourner en formation après enfin
ou retourner à l'emploi mais c'est juste
remettre le pied à
l'étrier développer des nouveau des
nouvelles compétences se sentir en
confiance avec les compétences qu'on
possède on le voit il y en a pour
certains qui savaient tout juste allumer
un ordinateur et qui et qui ressortent
de là dedans avec au moins des cordes en
plus et et des envies supplémentaires de
se dire aussi qu'on peut tout simplement
y arriver
après une formation de graphiste café
China 28 ans a décidé d'intégrer le
sprint camp pour acquérire de nouvelles
connaissances numériques en 3 jours elle
a créé sa propre page internet sur Wix
avec l'aide de sa formatrice Sandra je
me lance en freelance bon pour faire des
chates graphiques vraiment me
spécialiser dans l'achat graphique et
tout donc éventuellement aussi faire des
sites Web pour des gens habituellement
qu' connait pas quelque chose et queon
est en face d'une grande personne qu'on
est de quelqu'un qu'on est déjà adulte
on a du mal à poser des questions mais
c'était vraiment comme des discut et ça
pass crè ils ont une manière en fait de
t'apprendre sont de te rendre stupide
animation en Javascript ou création
graphique sur l'application qu'env va le
dernier jour de formation s'est conclu
le 29 septembre par une présentation des
différents projets entre les apprenants
une occasion de gagner en confiance
grâce à de nouvelles compétences
personnelles pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis le printemps dernier le
Technocentre Renault a ouvert son
nouveau bâtiment entièrement dédié à la
simulation de conduite immersive ce
centre abrite notamment le plus grand
simulateur de conduite du monde roads
installé dans un hall dédié ce nouvel
outil devrait permettre une meilleure
conception mais également une
accélération du processus de
développement des véhicules Renault pour
en parler je suis aujourd'hui en
compagnie d'Olivier Colmart directeur
ingénierie transformation digitale
simulation numérique et PLM bonjour
bonjour alors tout d'abord est-ce que
vous pouvez m'expliquer à quoi va servir
ce nouveau bâtiment alors on a construit
ce bâtiment spécialement pour notre
nouveau grand simulateur roads on en a
profité pour regrouper d'autres
simulateurs qu'on avait déjà au
Technocentre et puis les équipes en
charge de ces simulations immersives ont
été implantées dans le bâtiment moderne
et euh complètement fonctionnel
qu'est-ce que rods qu'est-ce que c'est
ce plus grand simulateur du monde alors
rose c'est un c'est un élément important
pour nous dans la conception comme vous
le savez de plus en plus on utilise de
la simulation numérique et donc euh
cette simulation numérique nous permet
de faire des simulations de crash
d'aérodynamique d'acoustique de
simulation des différents systèmes entre
eux mais toujours euh les résult
résultats sont obtenus avec des
équations des courbes et cetera un
véhicule c'est plus compliqué que ça
c'est aussi des critères subjectifs et
donc on a besoin d'un simulateur pour
remettre l'homme dans la boucle on va
pouvoir à l'intérieur de ce simulateur
reproduire des véritables scènes de
conduite donc on va pouvoir reproduire
des routes évidemment du trafic plus ou
moins dense on va pouvoir ajouter des
voitures des camions des vélos des
piétons mais on va aussi pouvoir faire
varier les conditions météorologiques on
va pouvoir créer du brouillard de la
pluie des conditions compliquées comme
de la neige on peut faire varier les
conditions d'adhérence de la route et
puis donc en gros faire un peu des
scènes accidentogène tout ce qu'on veut
et puis le le deuxième point très
important c'est qu'on va pouvoir aussi
agir sur le véhicule numérique que l'on
conduit donc on va pouvoir changer des
paramètres changer des réglages et
éventuellement faire tester au
conducteur différentes configurations
pour voir quelle est la configuration
quelle est la solution technique qu'il
préfère donc en gros plus besoin de
d'avoir une voiture physique et de faire
les simulations exactement exactement
donc on est capable pendant les PHAs les
phases de développement de la voiture de
tester notre véhicule sans construire de
prototype physique sans aller sur des
vraies pistes on est complètement
indépendant de la météo et on peut ainsi
concevoir avec robustesse et puis faire
que quand on on fera le premier
prototype physique on est quelque chose
déjà de très abouti et qui ira très vite
en production auprès de nos vrais
clients l'idée c'est de de de pouvoir
très très en amont tester nos futurs
véhicules en quoi est-ce que c'est une
avancée technologique considérable alors
c'est c'est une première mondiale
pourquoi d'abord par la je dirais la
taille du de de de du moyen que nous
avons développé le simulateur roads se
déplace sur des rails de 25 m par 25 m
c'est à peu près 90 tonnes en mouvement
donc on voit que c'est quelque chose
d'ampleur et puis en terme de
performance c'est aussi une première
mondiale puisque simulateur est capable
de reproduire des accélérations
supérieures à un
G on peut complètement s'immerger dans
le véhicule puisqueà l'intérieur du dome
on a un vrai véhicule un système de
projection à 360° et le conducteur a
vraiment l'impression de conduire un
véhicule avec les sensations
d'accélération de rouli et tangage merci
beaucoup merci à
[Musique]
vous le mesenas on pourrait dire que
c'est tout simplement le le don d'une
personne
morale privé que ce soit un particulier
ou une entreprise envers une structure
d'intérêt général pour soutenir une
cause qu'elle soit culturelle
environnemental ou
[Musique]
sociétal
alors on peut distinguer différents
types de mesena en particulier de mesena
d'entreprise on va avoir le mesena
financier bien sûr le meséna en nature
c'est lorsque par exemple l'entreprise
va donner du matériel informatique
qu'elle n'utilise plus et puis il y a le
messénat de
compétences là en fait il s'agit pour le
collaborateur volontaire de donner de
son temps de ses compétences de ses de
ses savoir-faire à une association à une
structure d'intérêt général sur son
temps de travail donc c'est forcément en
accord avec l'entreprise c'est pour ça
qu'on parle de Méen de compéten c'est
bien l'entreprise qui est mécène
puisqu'elle accepte de détacher un
collaborateur sur son temps de travail
au sein d'une
[Musique]
association c'est le mesena le plus
commun c'est c'est le don d'argent en
fait d'une personne morale envers une
structure d'intérêt général donc on peut
le faire à titre personnel bien sûr on
peut donner à une association et les
entreprises peuvent également donner bah
donner à des structures d'intérêt
général que ce soit pour des raisons
culturelles donc il y a des grands
mcenes en France qui ont aidé par
exemple pour le Louvre ou la Fondation
la Fondation LVMH et on peut aider en
fait dans tout tout types de secteur
l'entreprise peut donner de l'argent
pour pour que certaines causes en
bénéficient au niveau de l'association
fculine en fait on on accueille des
personnes on m notre compétence depuis
plusieurs années maintenant euh
notamment effectivement des des des
personnes qui sont salarié dans des
entreprises partenaires et c'est vrai
que ça nous permet au niveau de
l'association d'avoir des personnes
expérimenté qui vont effectivement
apporter beaucoup de choses au niveau de
l'association et qui vont nous permettre
justement aussi d'accompagner notamment
des des jeunes là en l'occurrence sur
sur leur projet professionnel et puis de
manière générale même sur leur projet de
vie je voulais m'investir dans les
écoles de Montini dans les collèges plus
particulièrement et il y avait ce volet
éducation qui qui
m'intéressait avec F et donc je me suis
investi depuis 3 4 ans maintenant merci
à tous d'avoir suivi ce nouveau numéro à
bientôt sur
[Musique]
tv78